starwars the last Jedi featured a
Skywalker leaving his lightsaber behind
but will Star Wars Episode nine see
another member of the legendary family
pick it up during a pivotal scene
according to leaked information
regarding the forthcoming installments
in the spacefaring saga it's apparently
a guarantee expressed recently obtained
the description of a tantalising Episode
nine scene that features Carrie Fisher's
general Leia wielding a classic Jedi
lightsaber the skywalker saber not only
as layers set to hold it in the film but
the headstrong Rebel Alliance leader
will reportedly or some ignitor the leak
claims that during an important sequence
in Episode nine layer is on a well that
appears to be a mix between Endor
Tatooine and jakku so basically the
middle of nowhere will be from nowhere
no one's from nowhere Jack ooh all right
that is pretty much nowhere speculation
is that this could be the planet of
Botto
located on the outer rim wearing a black
outfit that looks almost like a robe
layer is seen standing next to Mars
cannot sir c-3po and r2d2 holding the
Skywalker lightsaber and examining it
the scene description reads quote she
begins to hold it in a jedi-like stance
and activates it pointing it towards a
city that looks like it has gone through
battle though anyone force sensitive or
nuts can ignite a lightsaber it's
interesting to imagine layer activating
one giving her ties to the force film
fans were first made aware of layers
force sensitivity over 30 years ago in
the Empire Strikes Back
drawing the scene in which her twin
brother Luke implemented the force to
reach out to her thus granting Leia the
opportunity to save Luke from falling to
his death on Cloud City her force
responsiveness was again explored this
time in a much bigger way in 2017 the
last Jedi during an intense battle with
the first-order layer and the number of
her fellow rebels were flung into deep
space after an explosion destroyed part
of Leia ship it looked as though Leia
was done for but just as viewers began
preparing to say goodbye to Leia the
general channeled the force and used its
power to pull herself back onto the ship
however just because layer will
purportedly get a lightsaber in Episode
nine doesn't mean that she's channeling
the force and it also doesn't mean that
she has risen to replace her brother
Luke as the surviving Jedi of the
Skywalker family the
conclusive and explicit statements are
letting the exact opposite this has not
indicate that layer is a Jedi the stands
has done more in a victorious way it
could be the site of a first order
defeat overall episode nine including a
scene in which layer activates a
lightsaber seems entirely feasible and
it wouldn't be difficult for Abrams on
the horde of hyper talented
special-effects artists on board the
project to create a layer led sequence
several years after Fisher's death the
episode nine creative team will make use
of rotoscoping techniques to take
previously captured footage of Fisher as
Leia in the force awakens and the last
Jedi and place it over newly shot
material creating brand-new scenes for
Episode nine without resorting to making
a CGI version of Leia
we all know how about looks Bert's at
the end of the day this is an
unsubstantiated leak as with every rumor
fandom ade theory and wild piece of
speculations you should take these
details with a grain of salt sure the
information sounds awesome but none of
it has been confirmed Lucasfilm and the
entire episode 9 cast and crew are
keeping an airtight lid on details so we
can't imagine that anyone involved with
the upcoming pick will be rushing to
comment on this new leak anytime soon
everyone will just have to wait until
Star Wars Episode nine opens in December
2019 to find out if Leia truly does
light up a saber
[Music]